purity when you land on an alien planet
and think man things were really better
back home
so you pursue the purity affinity with
the goal of reshaping the planet in the
image of your dear old mum you bushwhack
through bugs clear out miasma and give
your sieve a kind of Art Deco Golden Age
revival sort of aesthetic classy but
what does it take to go all the way
earth and how are you going to convince
others who might not be on board with
your plans to earn the promised land
victory you start in the same place as
the emancipation victory by researching
orbital networks and launching a laser
comm satellite to get in touch with the
gang back on earth launch it over your
scientist city to use the 15% science
boost to speed you on your way to
nanotechnology which not only lets you
construct an exodus gate but also gets
you closer to the ultimate purity unit
the lev destroyer more on that one in a
second the exodus gate is a wonder that
you have to spend production to build
and also plunk down on an actual tile in
your territory close to your capital
would be good so you can bombard anyone
who comes to try to knock it down and
even better if you place it near your
mag rail lines or just like build some
mag rail lines near it radiating out
away from your cities it seems weird I
know but the whole point of this thing
is to bring folks over from Earth and
settle them on the new planet and you
can't put them in settlements within
three hexes of a city an outpost or a
station once the gate is complete you
can summon one settler per turn and you
got to Shepherd these scared little
newbies to settlements and plunk them
down you're going to need four spots in
total because each settlement can only
accommodate six settlers and you need a
total of 20 to win hopefully you've got
some room nearby but you may have to
evict some old tenants if space becomes
a problem
fortunately stations go down easy but if
other SIVs start getting real mad about
the promised land drawing closer the lev
destroyer is the perfect conflict
negotiation tool it can travel anywhere
but mountains and bombard within two
hexes though it takes a turn to set up
like most siege weapons but once it's
set up
buhbuh buhbuh Pugh
the cleansing fire rains down upon thine
enemies and their sins and cities are
washed away then it's just a matter of
getting your settlements set up packing
them full of earthlings and behold this
planet truly has become the promised
land praise be